during our time in the Big Brother house
I did conceive a little baby so funny
and serious but unfortunately and we
don't know why but I had a miscarriage
in the jury house and it's something
that we're still figuring out we
actually just got a chance to talk to
each other about it for the first time
today
Big Brother power couple Bailey and
swaggy C announcing that sad news Friday
less than 48 hours after they got
engaged on the Big Brother season finale
I don't really care about any girl in
the world I want you and only you and I
don't really know what my future holds
but I do know I want you in it yeah
decided to propose so the whole people
saying he's only proposing cuz I'm
pregnant thing that's hurtful
so stop ET was with sway Lee in the
backyard after the exciting moment where
they talks next steps but avoided
pregnancy talk congratulations you guys
can we see this ring first off how big
of a shock was this for you um scale of
one to ten maybe a 25 I was like
completely blindsided back door like
what the heck is going on well I gotta
say he walked over stood you up in
somebody in in on your side of the stage
was like is this a marriage proposal and
you went No and then it why no I didn't
even hear that I literally blacked out I
literally was like now it can't be like
I never thought that that was even gonna
be next and you can't make assumptions
like that like that's like what the heck
if it doesn't happen you get let down
all right
how did when did this un I'm gonna pop
the question to her on finale night when
did that come through four days ago
probably I want to say four or five days
ago like I had the ring I think two
weeks ago but I was like I'm gonna do it
later like I mean
but then as finale night got closer and
closer her mom started having dreams and
then after that having dreams or like
you know what I'm just going to organize
like I don't care basically it's my
mother no it's like I convinced her
cause like I mean I have long
conversations with your mom and dad like
three hours like this is what I'm gonna
do
like nobody doesn't stop me and they
loved it I was gonna say did you do the
right thing you got permission from the
parents who do this tonight what does it
mean to you that he spent so much time
getting to know your family I'm in love
with that like nobody has ever done that
before and then he went by himself
though real bold yeah all right what's
next are you moving to Missouri what's
happening Artie some of your BB 20
family has moved out here like Rachael
Winstone and Caitlin are all out here oh
my god you know we're gonna actually
move and to like a place maybe with
Hailey and vessel or maybe by ourselves
I don't know okay I want to take it back
to when you were like this is not a
marriage proposal was there ever a
second you were like I don't know if I'm
gonna say yes right now no there wasn't
like I didn't even have to see the ring
as soon as he got like on his knee I was
like oh my god yes like please but
that's like aggressive so I had to keep
it together you know just for like a
second and he did good this is a
government really good and he said he
got a little bit of help from my mom
like I would bring rings back to your
mom and dad like nope we don't want it
don't want it at least two weeks in a
row and then I found son I was like
that's the one oh good you've got a good
one here I gotta say can you play a
little rumor patrol with you you you
sparked the internet aflame you like
said something to Haley that people are
like she ending that she's having a sway
Lee baby no babies on the way right
yeah okay we got to focus on that we got
a wedding to plan
yeah are we gonna have a long engagement
or are we gonna jump right into marriage
I don't know that's very serious you're
just you have just gotten released from
the Big Brother well I'm open to either
way I don't really care but if we try to
go big or go home we might need some
time to like plan because it's gonna be
epic whatever it is yeah I wanna come
can I get in yes no no but yes please
come are you gonna put some of your BB
20 family in the wedding party yes for
sure I'm not even gonna go with names
but Haley is gonna be there rocket stove
all day yeah so everybody else I don't
know if I'm gonna make the list but
we'll see we gotta figure out what the
budget is how many people were inviting
all there's a lot of things in the air
Robyn Casper you don't know cast this
show she's the one who made this love
match happy yes and she didn't even know
yeah there's so many that are coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]